the day after the stick moons appeared
cara killed a bird that wasn't exactly
right there had been stick moons which
her parents called platforms as long as
carrick could remember at night they
glowed with reflected sunlight like
burnt orange bones and in the daytime
they'd been lines of white bent behind
the blue in her books the moon was
always a pale disk or a cookie with a
bite taken out but that was earth's moon
luna laconia was different so it wasn't
that they had appeared the night before
she killed the bird it was only that
they lit up red and blue and gold for
the first time ever hey guys pete here
today i'm going to talk about that odd
little alien looking creature that
showed up at the end of the expanse
season 6 trailer this is a scene from
one of my personal favorite novellas in
the book series and while that makes me
excited to see it i couldn't help but
wonder why they decided to add this to
what is being called the sixth and final
season the initial fan reaction included
a lot of proclamations that this sealed
the deal they were definitely planning
on making more expanse because why
include this otherwise the thing about
this story is it connects things to the
final trilogy and as i mentioned in my
trailer breakdown it doesn't really
change what's going on presently in
seoul system so that is the question
then does this mean that there's more
expanse on the horizon i would love to
believe that i would love for this to
mean that but i'm still skeptical so i
decided to look into it i'll be getting
into what i came up with and as far as
spoilers i'm gonna talk about the
premise of strange dogs i'm gonna get
into what the story is about without
giving away what happens it's a short
story and it looks like they might
include the whole thing and i don't want
to spoil that even a little bit for
people going into season six also
obviously i'll be talking about
everything that happened in the show
through season 5 including some of the
details at the end so if all that sounds
all right then let's get into it
if you read the book series in
publication order as you should and you
include the novellas strange dogs comes
right after the sixth book babylon's
ashes that's where the bulk of what
we're gonna see in the sixth season of
the television show comes from you would
read this story after you read that book
but chronologically speaking the only
thing that's actually important is that
the active proto molecule made it
through the ring gate with the martian
breakaway fleet you'll remember we did
see that happen at the end of season
five of the show and even though there
was an incident with the bar keith as it
was transiting the ring we saw that they
talked to cortazar he had gone with a
group that went ahead and there weren't
any other issues with the transits of
the rest of the breakaway fleet why
that's a necessary ingredient is because
part of what strange dogs is about is
what happens when that protomolecule
sample arrives and i think ultimately
this is why they included it in season
six the proto-molecule and the ring gate
builders don't play a crucial role in
the plot of what happens in babylon's
ashes there's a war going on between the
inner planets and the free navy in the
belt earth is dealing with the fallout
from the rocks and mars is dealing with
the after effects of that breakaway
fleet taking a lot of their military
hardware through the laconia gate they
traded more of that to the free navy
which is how they're able to cause all
these problems in the first place and
they traded it for that active
proto-molecule sample the only one
that's known right now in the story so
there's a lot going on that needs to be
resolved and while it's clear that our
core group of characters will have to
deal with that on almost all of my
season 6 videos that i put out so far i
get this same type of question about it
being the final season i'm wondering if
season 6 is going to explain what
happened to the gate builder
civilization and these unknown
aggressors that wiped them out and if
you're just looking at babylon's ashes
then the answer is pretty much no and
adding strange dogs doesn't actually
remedy this but i do think it does
something else which we'll get to and to
be fair the show has always been about
the characters it's always been about
these political conflicts with the
backdrop of colonizing our solar system
but the proto-molecule drove a lot of
that action and it's a super interesting
part of the story that people want to
know more about which is why it always
seemed like this might come up as an
issue people would have if they had to
end the series after the sixth season it
has a nice ending to everything that's
going on but there's still a lot of
natural questions you might have that
don't get answered until the final
trilogy which as of now there are no
official plans to adapt
so what is the story strange dogs about
it's a story told through the point of
view of a young girl named kara her
parents are scientists that came with
the first group that came to study
laconia after the ring gates opened cara
herself was a baby on the trip but
they've been there for eight years now
so she's from earth but she doesn't
remember that as laconia is the only
home she's ever known in the blurb i
read at the beginning of the video she's
talking about what she calls stick moons
that she can see in the laconian night
sky they had just lit up red and blue
and gold for the first time ever the
stick moons are the orbital platforms we
saw at the end of season 5. they're left
behind from the gate builder
civilization the same beings that
created the proto-molecule and sent it
out into the galaxy to create the rings
in the ring network also built these
things and this is a situation like we
saw when they visited illus in season
four it's also where that active
proto-molecule sample comes in you'll
remember what happened in season 4 when
the rossi accidentally brought some of
the proto-molecule to the planet gate
builder tech started to come back online
things started to turn on and this is a
foundational element in the plan of the
breakaway fleet who will eventually call
themselves laconians and again they made
that clear at the end of season five so
strange dogs is a story about what
happens on laconia after these things
start turning back on remember cara and
her family they were just there on a
scientific mission with a group of other
first landers from the inner planets
while they were there marco threw the
rocks at earth the ring gates got cut
off that means that they're disconnected
from the inner planets and this military
force with all these martian ships
arrived to take over the planet and all
the gate builder tech that comes along
with it so we see that play out and it's
interesting on a couple different levels
for one we get to see a whole new planet
and what it's like to settle one of
these places that has a different tree
of life that isn't compatible with ours
from earth and we get to see the early
days of laconia and what they're trying
to do there while getting introduced to
some of the characters that will show up
in the final three books so that's it
then if they're making this a part of
what's now being advertised as the final
season then they must be setting things
up for future adaptations they haven't
announced yet right i mean not exactly
it does do that but those stories
already exist in book form the final one
is coming out in just a couple of days
from when i'm making this video also the
martians were a big part of what was
going on in season five so if you didn't
show any of this all you would really
know about them is that they conspired
with marco and so even though i'd like
to think that it means that there's more
on the horizon i do think it does make
sense to include this even if there
isn't some secret plan out there that
they're waiting to announce it
reinforces that idea that we've seen
play out several times throughout the
series of humans trying to use the
proto-molecule to their advantage even
though they don't understand what the
consequences will be if you can't have
an end to the whole story then i do
think that's what the end should be
given what we've seen throughout the
story and everything we know about
humanity this is what we should expect
would be happening regardless of how bad
things have gone in the past at the end
of season 5 avasarala says why would
they take the proto-molecule knowing
what happened on ellis and holden says
maybe they know something we don't and i
mean they do have cortisol we know that
but you still kind of figure that it's
just wishful thinking that they think
that they'll be able to figure it out
and it's just that potentially powerful
people just can't help themselves they
assume that if they don't take it and
use it somebody else will and as far as
this little creature cara calls it a dog
and that's where the book gets its name
strange dogs i'll just say that this guy
is a bit of gate builder tech that
turned back on and leave it at that
because as i said i don't want to spoil
what happens in the story beyond that i
think that this tale is best told as it
has been in the books there's no good
way that i can see that you could
shortcut things to get to the end of the
proto-molecule story in an effort to try
to satisfy everyone who's been watching
the show the way it's been told things
take time to develop and it's worth it
when you get there so at least you could
go read the books if it never happens if
it never gets adapted as i said before
at its core this is a story about people
how these really great characters react
to the situations they find themselves
in we've watched as their proximity to
the changes that are happening in soul
system as a result of the proto molecule
has led them to some fantastic
adventures the main conflict now is the
economic and political changes brought
on by the ringgate's opening in season
three this made the prospects and lives
of belters which weren't great before
much worse it made the martian dream the
terraforming project irrelevant and all
of those things created a situation
where a man like marco inaros could
emerge and try to take power for himself
try to get revenge against the inner
planets for all of the exploitation that
they brought about in the belt and i
think that is a good place to leave it
so let me know what you think i'm really
excited to see them bring this story to
life like i said it is one of my
favorites and all the novellas are
pretty good and i'm still disappointed
that this is the last season so we have
to live with it i'm not without hope
that someday we might see the final
trilogy things that the writers have
said and in particular things that wes
chatham and dominique tipper have said
in interviews make it seem as though
there were at least conversations going
on or at the very least that alcon is
optimistic about getting more made let
me know what you think in the comments
what you're hoping to see and if you
want to talk book spoilers just mark
those so we don't spoil things for
people who only watch the tv show please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon